and that is um
yesterday you went
to see some museum in the netherlands
you went to boymonds you went to the
margaret's house
and it's nice to have a small country i
can go to two major cities oh yes
um and and i would like to to to
to see if it's possible to
to to put your lecture into the context
of the discussion we are having now in
the netherlands about the meaning of
arts and culture in general
because you made a remark at the end of
your lecture about that
the museum is now from mission driven
turning into market driven and
this is exactly the new policy by
well new it is now very much the policy
of the government there are serious
budget cuts in all
fields of the arts and the message from
the political world is
less mission driven and be much more
market driven
what's your take on this
you've asked
you've completed two questions um
i will answer second
uh and since i'm 76 i would have
forgotten what that is you'll remind me
of it
um
the first part of it the the market
driven uh versus the uh
the art driven um
was really brought home to me
uh after my wonderful visit of the of
the boymonds which is the place i love
and getting to
the hague and i know that
i am
meant to be entirely polite to my host
but i will have to tell you that you
walk into the maori's house
and as you turn towards the
ticket
area
there are two huge posters of vermeer's
girl with a pearl earring
wherever you turn you see an image of
that picture
i will tell you something i did not go
and look at the painting i was so
enraged it had been turned from a
painting into an image into an
illustration on the coffee mug
that the very that the very place that
displays the original should cover
itself with posters of that image is
simply inexcusable
and so
fortunately
one of the most gorgeous girls excuse me
women
in the world is at the maui's house
and it is not the girl with the purl
earring it is a little painting by
bartel bruyne
which is in a vitrine
with deep
sensual eyelids she's absolutely
heavenly and she made up for
she made up for it for me uh look her up
bartelboine uh maori choice i've
forgotten her name um
but in any event uh that's the first
part of it i think museums just have to
be careful about things such as that
it's an interesting thing in the history
of art and that's a tangent there are
some major figures who actually are
better image makers and they are
painters
i would say that for example uh
of um
um
uh
the the belgian surrealist
magnet magritte is a bad painter but
he's a fabulous image maker
and so on and so forth but
the mayor is a great painter don't make
him a good image maker okay
the other part of it is a much more
complicated
issue that of the government the cuts to
the arts and this and so forth
um
i exercise my meter in a country with
all museums except the smithsonian in
washington are private there are no fun
the met doesn't receive any money from
washington it receives a little bit from
the city of new york for guardianship
but if we said tomorrow to this day we
wouldn't need it you wouldn't notice it
so it's it's it's minimal uh it's
entirely based on the money given by
a great many donors many of whom are on
the board of trustees this is why we put
them on the board of trustees
and
well it's just a fact of life
and
the issue here is that i cannot
altogether condemn
and
having
been born french and also a country
where all of the museums are our state
institution i've certainly worked
closely i'm on the board of trustees of
the museum say i've just come from a
meeting there
where the government is also
cutting subsidies to a number of places
these governments and the museums are in
a conundrum because on the one hand
there is ingrained in the society in the
minds of all of you
that well if you do not disperse any
money somehow the state will
that is not an incentive for you to go
into your pocket and give money
if a
if a state
whose cultural institutions
are dependent on the state is going to
cut back
i do not believe it should do so until
it has put in place those structures
usually fiscal structures to allow for a
smooth transition to the private sector
such as subventions to corporations to
be able to make up the gap or tax
deductions for individuals who make
gifts but simply
cold turkey
to simply remove the money when the
culture is not there
for donation seems to be
not wise